la fédération internationale des
journalistes et le collectif belgium for
assange main dans la main les deux
associations ont écrit cette semaine au
maire de bruxelles
objectif que la capitale belge adoptent
julian assange
à l'instar d'autres défenseurs de la
liberté d'expression
le co fondateur de wikileaks a vu ses
demandes d'extradition vers les états
unis rejetée par la justice britannique
début janvier
le lanceur d'alert australien accusé
d'avoir divulgué des milliers de
documents classés secret défense est
toujours incarcéré à londres dans la
prison de haute sécurité de belmarsh il
serait selon la fédération
internationale des journalistes en très
mauvais état
on en parle avec pascal viel à membres
du collectif belge n fera sans jay
professeur de droit à l'université de
louvain en belgique
bonjour pascal vielle merci de répondre
à nos questions ce matin en direct sur
rt france votre association et la
fédération internationale des
journalistes a donc écrit au socialiste
philippe close le bourgmestre de
bruxelles pour l'adoption par la
capitale belge de julian assange
quand vous dites adopté qu'est ce que
vous entendez par là
alors en fait bruxelles fait partie d'un
réseau de villes appelées ville lumière
qui qui qui ont pris l'engagement de
défendre les droits humains et
l'adoption dans ce contexte là c'est
laval le fait d'accueillir de s'engager
à accueillir est donné à à une personne
qui défend les droits humains et qui est
en danger
un statut en quelque sorte d'accueil de
protection de facilitation de séjour à
bruxelles
voilà en recette consiste et bruxelles
vient de donner ce statut d'ailleurs à
deux personnes d'arabie saoudite
deux militants des droits humains il
s'agit de l'eau jeunes bénin
à la clown et à rice badaoui et nous
espérons beaucoup évidemment que la
ville va accepter cette demande qui
s'inscrit d'ailleurs dans un dans un
mouvement populaire plus large de
demande de protection de julian assange
dans différents pays du monde et parfois
avec un caractère encore beaucoup plus
des 2/3 il alors c'est pas vrai le droit
d'asile
il s'agit de la ville de bruxelles elle
n'est pas en mesure de donner le droit
des îles c'est une facilitation de
séjour mais plusieurs pays s'engagent
aujourd'hui sous la pression populaire
sous l'opinion publique sous la pression
de l'opinion publique a donné à julian
assange
une forme de protection qui lui disent
ou qui lui ouvre des options de mobilité
en fait sa situation est particulière
parce que si aujourd'hui il est demain
il est libéré au royaume-uni et que les
états unis n'ont pas levé les charges
qui pèsent contre lui
il y à cette épée de damoclès qui
répliques continuent de peser sur sa
tête et qu'il empêche de sortir du
royaume uni parce qu'il risque d'avoir
un mandat d'arrêt dans d'autres pays du
monde et donc chaque pays qui lui offre
une protection
c'est une manière de dire eh bien nous
vous ouvrons des options de mobilité
c'est aussi une manière de dire quelque
part royaume uni qui reste tout de même
même s'il y a eu bris exit membres de la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme royaume uni etats unis vous
agissez sous le regard des nations du
monde donc à la fois une dimension
officielle et une dimension symbolique
très forte et quelles sont les chances
que cette demande aboutisse alors les
chances écouter
je pense que les chances sont plus
élevés qu'il y a un an nous avions
adressé une demande analogue un peu
différente à la ville il ya un an
mais aujourd'hui je pense que la
sensibilisation à la situation de julian
assange dans les pays européens en tout
cas et au fait que derrière sa situation
personnelle il ya un enjeu démocratique
fort c'est-à-dire notre droit à
l'information et la liberté de la forme
de la liberté de la presse
cette sensibilisation est aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus forte et je crois que les
autorités publiques entende ce message
donc nous avons bon espoir et au delà du
symbole si cette requête devait donc
aboutir quelles seraient les
conséquences d'un point de vue juridique
et au niveau de sa protection
alors au niveau de sa protection
juridique je vais vous dire pas vraiment
de conséquences
le fait est qu si il voulait se déplacer
en belgique la ville de bruxelles
s'engagerait à l'accueillir et à lui
donner et à lui faciliter son séjour à
la fois sourd du sur le plan
administratif et sur le plan logistique
je dirais si l'état belge je lui donnais
une protection à l'ordre dans quelque
chose d'un peu différent qui peut
prendre différentes formes par exemple
si on regarde ce que fait la suisse
aujourd'hui le canton de genève a requis
de la confédération helvétique
un visa humanitaire de trois mois
renouvelable qui lui permettrait d'aller
se faire soigner très concrètement donc
ça peut prendre des tags forme différent
je vais vous parler de les faire soigner
on le sait les relations de jeu
et dans une santé has et défaillante la
fédération internationale des
journalistes insiste d'ailleurs sur ce
point
est-ce que son état s'est dégradé ces
derniers jours comment va-t-il
exactement vous avez des nouvelles
je n'ai pas de nouvelles aussi récente
non je n'ai pas de nouvelles les
dernières nouvelles que l'on colle on
connaît officiellement ce sont les
nouvelles de qui date de l'audience du 4
janvier dans laquelle la juge a constaté
qu'il a qu'il présentait un risque très
élevé de suicide donc sa santé mentale
eve
il est vraiment en péril et malgré
qu'elle ait fait ce constat qu'elle est
posée ce constat et malgré qu'il soit
dans des conditions d'isolement aggravée
par le par l'épidémie que vite qui vous
le savez sévit de manière très virulente
en angleterre eh bien elle n'a pas
accepté de de le relâcher
et donc on attend avec grande impatiente
soit que les etats-unis peut-être avec
l'arrivée de joe biden lèvent leurs
accusations soit qu'une décision d'appel
a conclu à à à sa libération
voilà oui puisqu'on leur appel à sa
demande d'extradition vers la washington
a été rejetée par la justice britannique
mais le parquet a fait appel merci et
pascal à vielle d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
membre du collectif belgium fond à
saint-gilles et professeur de droit à
l'université de louvain en belgique